no substitute for work ethic i'm sure  that probably comes up a lot but  recruitment is hard work and there's  there's no  there's no getting around that but i  think really  a willingness and desire to  connect with people on a human level  you have to work in a really green way  when you are a billing manager  the job is to get people to be able to  to do this job very well  you know autonomously they're not really  setting their people  up to do the job autonomously like  they're jumping in  and doing stuff for them so i think it's  all about do it properly  with the first people that you on board  and  work really green and actually those  initial people  they'll be super competent too and that  that's how you that's how you grow a  team effectively  and you don't do it alone people don't  have imposter syndrome who are not  self-aware  because you're actually very aware of  where you are and what your experience  is and you think quite critically about  yourself